[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
autant les pompiers oui c'est beau et
port de bouc et je suis là d'or ou là
ou si vous avez un super pouvoir ce
serait quoi franchement manu serait quoi
ton pouvoir mettre un kiff volley volley
volley ball et à autant les cristina
s'étaient transportés de transporter
prend la finance gardien koné seydou tu
fais ça tu es là tu es surpris ça serait
bien
vous vous serez comme invisible ça va
casser si l'ama super pouvoir ce serait
de ne pas payer de pension alimentaire à
notre première mariée c'est un
spécialiste du mariage puisqu'il s'est
marié tellement de fois que son salaire
se transforme automatiquement en pension
alimentaire
benjamin castaldi alors tu vas devoir
dire manif ait ou dégueulasse
d'accord d'accord manif avec ou
dégueulasse
benjamin castaldi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous êtres invisibles et oui mais
voulait être dans l'émission
[Applaudissements]
non moi je l'avais dit avant demain si
je connais l'état je voudrais tout au
bout et à laëtitia
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
matthieu delormeau serait pas où j'étais
un peu plus égoïste un jeu un peu
moindres on connaît encore plus visible
[Musique]
ça va la banque arabe à rome
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vraiment vous avez un tennis comment
sont les choses
tennis alors sinon on lire dans les
pensées lire dans les pensées
on ne faut pas tant faut pas y penser
voici l a lu dans mes pensées
elle sait déjà qu'elle doit trouver un
boulot pour l'année prochaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]